Joe Rogan was just talking to the Rock
and Joe Rogan is an independent voter he
was a Bernie bro then he signaled that
he kind of liked Trump he never really
liked Biden probably to establishment
for Joe he's talking to The Rock The
Rock for many years has been rumored to
be a republican but he's endorsed plenty
of lib stuff I think he endorsed Biden
in
2020 these these guys are probably
pretty decent reflections of the
American populist at large here's their
conversation about the sitting president
of the United States when I was a
kid you could have a republican friend
like it it was no big deal yes no big
deal like oh Bobby likes George Bush who
cares who gives a you know you were a
supporter of Bill Clinton he liked
George Bush nobody cared nobody like you
you know it wasn't like you're a Nazi
like I'm a what I mean I'm a Nazi I just
want lower
tax what the you talking about how did I
become a Nazi dude it's it's the
craziest thing I have friends who
support Trump I have friends who support
Biden I have friends do you really have
friends who support Biden come on no no
no no no no here's here's what I do I
have I have friends thank you that's a
good check cuz that's important this is
important context they support the
Democratic party I have friends who are
loyal to the party
yes no
devastating and really great catch by
Joe because the rock is trying to do
this thing that entertainers have done
since Michael Jordan and long before
that long before Michael Jordan he made
it Famous by saying well Republicans buy
sneakers too but it's the notion that I
don't want to alienate either side of
the political aisle so I'm yeah I've got
friends who who support Trump I have
friends who support Biden and Joe just
leans in he goes BS no you don't nobody
supports Biden I know for a fact you
don't have a single friend who supports
Biden right and The Rock looks at him he
knows he's caught and he goes
yeah okay you're right yeah but I have
Democrat friends but even the Democrats
hate Joe Biden and they don't hate him
with passion I guess that's that's even
more of an indictment of Biden nobody
passionately hates Joe Biden he's
just so so
unimpressive he's just the guy who was
there I mean in part that's why he got
elected yeah that's the ticket that's he
wound up president is because he was
just totally acceptable and not
exceptional or impressive in any way he
had been around Washington DC since
1752 and he had never rocked the boat
too much he doesn't really believe
anything he'll just go wherever he feels
the wind of his party is blowing e even
his corruption is not that impressive
Clinton corruption is really impressive
the clintons formed this Foundation they
went all over the world they collected a
ton of money they shook down foreign
governments totally in public view Bill
Clinton's flying around at Jeffrey
Epstein's private airplane he's
flaunting it they're flaunting their
corruption it was so outrageous and in
your face Joe Biden he's sending his son
around his drug addled son to go shake
down some oligarchs in Ukraine or in
China or it's kind of behind the scenes
and it's just even that even the
corruption is just so
mediocre nobody supports him so what's
what's that going to mean
it's going to mean that if the election
is fair and if the Republicans can fix
the way that the Dems rigged the voting
in 2020 then a republican has a pretty
good chance of winning right now go to
Pur talk.com if you're looking for a
killer Black Friday deal I've got one
for you a free Moto
g5g phone from P talk no gimmicks no
trade in necessary just sign up for p
Talk's unlimited talk unlimited text and
15 kig data you can get all this for
just 35 bucks you will get the Moto G 5G
phone for free phones these days cost so
much money well you get it for free the
new Moto g5g boasts a two-day battery
life that's outrageous an exceptional
quad pixel camera and a whole lot more
this is a great deal but you will need
to move fast because the phones will be
sold out by the end of the month so if
your current phone is on the way out
upgrade for free with P talk P talk
gives you America's most Dependable 5G
Network at half the price make the
switch today go to Pur talk.com
nscw to get this exclusive offer and
select the plan that is right for your
family that is Pur talk.com
nscw to claim your free Moto g5g phone
with a qualifying plan that is Pur
talk.com canes Pure Talk simply smarter
Wireless right now go to jus.com if you
can believe it Thanksgiving is next week
just in time for the holidays genus cell
is offering their best sale of the year
right now you can get 70 70% off genus
cell's most popular package which now
includes genus cell 3 their newest under
eye treatment genus cell 3 will have you
looking 10 15 even 20 years younger it
uses advanced technology to deliver
complex vitamins and minerals directly
to your face for instant hydration say
goodbye to Fine Lines crows feet under
eye bags and dark spots Jus cell will
have you looking and feeling your
absolute best guaranteed or your money
back no questions asked our talent
manager Tessa loves using the genus cell
under eye cream a lot of people at this
office love genucel but I can't tell you
how good they all look because HR will
yell at me if I do that but genus cell
this is the real deal man the genus cell
products are all made with the absolute
highest quality ingredients and right
now you can get an incredible 70 70% off
at Jus cell.com I asked how can you
afford to to Discount this
70% is it just a big markup and I was
talking this to the founder of the
company and he said no no we're going to
lose money when we do that but we are so
confident that you're going to love the
products that you're going to keep
getting the products for years and years
into the future get results in 12 hours
or less the immediate effects are
included for free jus.com 70% off plus
free priority shipping J cell.com NS is
another man running for president
potentially that would be West Virginia
senator Joe Mansion Are you seriously
contemplating a run for the White House
I'm going to do everything in my power
to make sure and mobilize that moderate
sensible common sense midle that could
be a center left center right so it
could be a person who is involved in the
grand old party forever but they
basically said well you know my Democrat
friends over here the old Blue Dog
Democrats The Middle's gone there's not
many of us Centrist left and if I can
reinvigorate that and I said I will do
everything that I possibly can I'm
totally absolutely scared to death that
Donald Trump would become president
again I think we will lose democracy as
we need know it I do just want to stick
with what your thinking is right now
just to clarify just to put a fine point
I know you haven't made any decisions
but are you considering running for
president I will do anything I can to
help my country is that a yes and you're
saying does that mean you would consider
it absolutely every American should
consider if they're in a position to
help save the country I think we're on
the wrong course so I will do everything
possible he wants to run he obviously
wants to run and he's he ex apparently
explored a No Labels run as an
independent candidate now he could he
could run as a Democrat to me the key
here the key figure in his thinking is
not Joe Biden to me the key figure in
his thinking is RFK Jr because RFK Jr is
styling himself as a 1960s Democrat I'm
a Kennedy Democrat you know I look my
name's Kennedy I'm a Kennedy Democrat
and I'm a little more moderate and a
little more Centrist and that's why you
should vote for me and Joe mansion's
looking at that and saying hey Bobby
Kennedy you're not a Centrist what are
you talking about you're an extreme
liberal on most issues other than the
covid vaccines which is why you have
some conservative support but but a lot
especially in the environment for
goodness sakes you're an extreme liberal
and you you've convinced people you're a
moderate and you're walking away with
one fifth of the Democrat vote right now
whoa and there was a poll that came out
last week in a three-way race you put a
real Dent you you're a real player in
this race whoa well if you're the fake
moderate what about me I'm an actual
moderate I'm Joe Mansion I'm the
Centrist guy Everyone likes me in the
Senate I'm I'm a I'm like a big cool
football quarterback you know I'm the
guy in high school that everybody likes
even the Democrats and the Republicans I
I pal around with everybody maybe I
should run that's what we're seeing here
boy what a great clip that was huh that
was good that was good now you got to
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
nolles YouTube channel I'll see you next
time